[Music]
everyone buys water from the water mafia
the rich the poor the middle-class
that's because Delhi and its
surroundings have about twenty four
million people and anywhere between
thirty percent to forty percent don't
have access to municipal water and as
the black market water trade became more
organized the trucks got bigger the
people who were controlling it were
richer now the water mafia behaves in a
way that this water will last forever
but as temperatures continue to rise the
mafia is finally going to run out of
water and that's when we're really going
to have a problem
the status of the world's fresh water
supply today is a crisis as big as
anything out there less than 1% of the
world's water is accessible for human
use populations are going up as
economies grow and countries develop
they use more and more water and we're
polluting what there is making it less
and less accessible water scarcity is
with us here and now warmer temperatures
less predictable rains will all combine
to make societies a little less stable
people generally have three sets of
responses to water scarcity they can
adapt if they have the resources they
can move or they can suffer and die and
if they're moving this becomes a
security concern worldwide
[Music]